in Portuguese churches in schools in
priests homes and in confessionals for
at least 70 years religious men were
abusing their positions of trust to
abuse the children in their care the
victims were mostly boys usually between
10 and 14 years old but the youngest was
just two at a press conference on Monday
the commission investigating the crimes
delivered the results of their year-long
mission
these testimonies as we will explain
ahead carefully allow us to reach to a
much more extensive victim Network
calculated at a minimum number absolute
minimum of
4815 victims
the Portuguese independent commission
was set up in November 2021 it was after
a similar body in France revealed 200
000 victims of child abuse in the French
Church
and there are those who think the
Portuguese investigation should have
uncovered comparable numbers
the numbers are pathetically small and I
think they're totally implausible
in France very recently there was a
report done
that concluded that there were a third
of a million victims over a very similar
period to the one that Portugal has been
looking at
um and so that means that there's only a
little over one percent of the number in
Portugal like Catholic authorities in
many countries around the world
Portuguese Bishops are struggling to
respond to a self-inflicted crisis
that's brought deep suffering to its
victims and severely damaged a supposed
Bastion of morality
we are aware as a church that we are a
church that makes and has made and will
certainly make mistakes I can't
guarantee that tomorrow there won't be
another case of abuse I would love to
say that but I don't I cannot say it
what I can say is that we have a
different Consciousness today it wasn't
easy for us to go down this path either
but we did it because we had to it is
essential to have the truth
for the Portuguese victims prospects for
justice are mixed 25 testimonies have
been sent for criminal investigation but
the rest are outside the 20-year statute
of limitations so nothing can be done
Rory challenge Al Jazeera